Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello.
Good afternoon.
It is. It is nicely just afternoon. I'm
only a few minutes late. Thank you for
joining me today, Adrian. How are you?
I'm good. Yeah. I'm considering
the circumstances,
but yeah.
It's a good day to be inside because
it's raining. So so
Yeah. Where are you based right now?
I'm currently in Berlin. Yep. So I I
I work here at at wire
for the past year now.
I moved to Berlin, and then I ended
up working from home in Berlin because the
office is closed, obviously. So this was not
completely as planned, but it's still fun. And
yep.
And I will probably
plug that we're hiring people for Kubernetes
things if you're interested in that at the
end of the show, but it's not always
looking for more people.
And but, yeah, I do
DevOps stuff there. So I do both development
and operations
responsible for
keeping all our
all our infrastructure running and building new features.
So we're kind of a mixed team. We
do all kinds of stuff.
And in my spare time, I also torture
myself with
these kind of things.
And yeah. Actually, I I didn't
have I p v six at home in
Netherlands because we only have, like, 15%
adoption rates, like, one of the lowest in
the world. And Germany,
it's, like, 70%.
It's super high.
And so when I moved here, I noticed
I had an I p v six address,
not only one. I had a trillion per
machine on everything on my network. Was like,
this is very weird, and how does this
work? And and I decided to learn a
bit about it by messing around with it
in Kubernetes, and that was a bit of
an adventure.
So
Well, I'm hoping that we can take all
of your learnings from that adventure. And Yeah.
I can absorb some of them, and we
can share some of them with people that
are watching as well. Yep. It's gonna be
awesome. Yeah. So they're also quite involved
in Next. Right? You're you're my go to
Next person.
Yeah. Yeah. So I do I
do maintenance
for NextOS.
I I maintain the the the system d
packages
and the that also touches all the container
stuff automatically.
So kind of in that area, making sure
that service management works in the next OS
and having all that stuff running. And I
also do the let's encrypt stuff for next.
So automatic certificate renewal for if you create
an NGINX service with the next OS and
stuff. Yeah. That's a lot of fun. Yeah.
It is
yeah. Also, if you want to check out
this project later, it's also set up with
next. It will download the right version of
Kubernetes and everything. It's
yeah.
Awesome.
Yep. So
I'm trying to
I guess my first question then, you know,
which I've straight into the
the the why. Why why are we doing
Kubernetes
I p v six only cluster?
Yeah.
So
what did you think the first time you
learned about, like, Kubernetes networking?
What was it very obvious to you, or
were you very confused? Because I was very
confused the first time I read about all
these things. Like, overlay networks, spot network,
service IPs,
net cube proxy. It's it's it's
like
Oh, yeah. It's very confusing. There's so much
to speak in, so many different components. And
then depending on the CNI implementation, there's different
abstractions on top of that. Yeah. Yeah. So
you have to choose, like the first thing
is, like, Kubernetes is gonna make super everything
super easy
once you make all these difficult choices. Right?
Like, there's 20 different CNI plug ins with
your VXLAN,
IP overlay networks,
or you can use the stuff from your
cloud provider to set up routing.
There's like a
million different choices. Right? And
so, one of the first
promises that Kubernetes makes is like your pod
network is flat. Every pod needs to be
able to talk to every pod without any
netting or whatever. Every pod gets an IP
and it needs to be reachable for each
other. Right?
And
kind of the the thing with that is
is that means you need to have a
unique IP address for each pod that you
spawn up.
And
with I p v four, that's kind of
expensive because I p v four addresses are
not cheap. So what we usually have is
we assign pods private addresses, and then we
set up this overlay network using,
I don't know, some IP and IP overlay
network or something such that all the pods
can talk to each other.
And
and the only reason why we have this
overlay abstraction is really because we
we cannot give each pod a public IP
address and let just
routing magic happen. Right?
And
then
IPv6
was designed, I don't know, twenty five years
ago. And they said, well, what if we
just make this address space bigger and then
we can just give every device a public
IP address? And then we don't need to
bother with netting and overlay networks and
all this stuff. And
every device gets a public IP address, and
we just
set up routing tables such that things route
the correct way. And
this makes
the world a lot easier in my head
because I don't have to think about what
is the IP address of my router when
I it's just when I go to a
website, they see the public IP of my
laptop. This it's just a it's a one
way route. Right?
And this also makes the whole it fits
very well this pod networking model. Like, every
pod has an IP, and each pod can
reach every other pod. Like, it fits this
I b v six world perfectly.
And we do not need to well, we
can still do overlay networks and all this
stuff, but we don't have to. If we
just
assign everything a public IP and we make
sure that there's
routes between the two node or three worker
nodes, they they know that they can route
both IPs from one to the other, Then
we can just expose all pods directly to
the Internet, and then people will say, what?
It's not secure. What what are you doing?
Yeah. We'll get to that to that later.
So I think for that, IPv6 is really
cool because it really fits this network model
of we have a flat network very well.
And that's like the basis of Kubernetes networking
is we have this flat network model.
And if we pick it, then we have
a lot less stuff
to
worry about.
So I think that's a bit of a
reason why I think I v v six
and Kubernetes is useful.
Also, yeah, you you get a lot of
IP addresses. So you don't have to worry
about all this IP address management and how
many how many pods can I schedule and
I don't know? They're infinite. You don't care.
It's just if you want to schedule a
trillion pods, it will still work. But so,
yeah, just having a flat address space makes
things a lot easier.
And Exactly. Yeah. So
there are a couple of things there. First,
Adrian. Thanks for watching. Second,
I just giggled that as you were chatting
there about IPv six being 25 years old.
And I was like, oh, I remember I
read a story about we ran out of
IPv four addresses.
Yeah. And that actually happened the first time
in 2015, I believe, North America ran out
of addresses. And then, officially, all IPv four
exhaustion happened in 2018.
It's been more two years.
Yeah. We still haven't gotten that sorted yet.
Right? Yeah. Correct.
But today, we're gonna do it. We're we're
we're gonna have a I p v six
Kubernetes cluster.
Exactly. So
Yeah. Is the security like, I mean, the
first thing when you say, let's get every
node an I'm desynchronous. Like, you mentioned the
security. Is that something you wanna talk about
now, or we'd say that as we began
to spend this up?
So
I left it as an exercise for the
reader, of course. No. But we'll talk about
it at the end. But I think we
have a good story
for it.
So,
basically, if everything is public, you're forced to
make proper firewall rules. That's basically the trick.
Instead of relying on the fact that your
overlay network is not reachable from the Internet,
this is all but security through obscurity. Right?
It's not that you and
Kubernetes has some very nice things for this.
So, you have network policies where you can
describe declaratively what pods can talk to what
pods. And
if your CNI provider supports it, it will
make your network secure. And you can also
do things like, I don't know,
service meshes like HCO to have everything encrypted.
And this is all levels that you put
on top. We'll start with every pod can
reach every pod. As a side effect, it
will mean the whole world can reach every
pod because it's IPv6 and everything is public.
But
if we start from the basis is very
simple, then we can bolt on security later.
And, yes, it is important, but it is
also important if your pods have private IP
addresses.
Because, I don't know, maybe
for some reason, you have some rule in
your firewall that forwards things to your prod
IP space. And then still things from the
outside could reach it. So it's always good
to have this kind of network policy set
up inside your Kubernetes cluster. And making everything
public by default, we're kind of forced to
do this zero trust thing, right, where we
trust nobody and we have to bolt everything
together.
But
I'm not sure if we're gonna get to
that part, but I can give some links
on how you could set that up. But
we're just gonna go for a very insecure,
very public Kubernetes cluster today,
I think.
Okay. So yeah. So, I mean, I've got
dozens of questions. But rather talking about it
abstractly, I think we we get started, we
put it together, and then Yep. The moving
components allow people to kinda follow along as
well. Yep. And there's just a little bit
of noise
in your mic, if you could just push
it away a little bit.
Better? Yeah. Sometimes it picks up the the
briefing if it gets too close. Yep. Just
tell me just tell me when it happens
again because it tends to slowly move back.
Yeah. Yep. That's alright. Perfect. Okay. So I
am gonna share
my screen.
I have, at your request, created a server.
The reason we have a working node server
is because
this cluster is only available in the I
p d six space, and my ISP does
not allocate me an I p d six
address per virtual version.
So
that server is here so that we can
interact with that customer needs. It's the only
reason I will be working remotely today.
Mhmm. I have a Versus Code window here,
which if I create
a a little text,
your cursor should magically show up. So we
have the ability to collaborate on this as
we go, which means that you get to
fix all of my errors, which is awesome.
And we have a terminal where I have
configured
just enough and hopefully not forgotten anything to
get us through this. So I have prepared
Terraform. I have installed Terraform,
Kube CPL,
Pulumi.
Yep. We we will need
one more thing that we need to install.
We're gonna need to well,
on a kubectl, we don't need. We need
that on the notes. That's gonna be fine.
We'll need calicoctl
as well because we're gonna use the Calico
network plugin in this demo.
And
it uses its own command line tool to
configure things.
So,
uses
custom resource Kubernetes
custom resource definitions,
but not for everything.
So for some things, you still need their
their CLI.
So yeah.
No problem. So we curl that. Shimon plus
x. Oh, yeah. We'll give that a second.
There we go.
Now we can move this.
Yep.
Okay. So we have everything we need. And
if we need anything else, we'll deal with
that as we go.
Yep. Alright.
Step one. What do I need to do?
So we will need some servers. Right? So
I will need a
a master node and some worker nodes
so we can
set those up.
Okay.
And I've never used Pulumi before, so I'm
very curious. It's
Yep. I'll talk about why I like it.
This director is an empty site, so why
need to add this force.
I'm using the packet TypeScript
template, which just means that it configures the
the provider to provision packet infrastructure,
and I'm gonna choose to write my code
in TypeScript. One of the things I really,
really, really, really love about Pulumi
is that you can use
most well, supported programming languages. So you can
use the tools you're comfortable with. For me,
I use TypeScript. You may wish to use
Go or Python, and even .net is supported.
So it's cool.
Now this wizard is going to ask me
for the project name,
description,
and stack name. Oh,
let's call it prod.
And something I really like about Pulumi as
well is it has a configurable
secrets provider.
Mhmm. By default, I can just type in
a
release secure
password.
And, hopefully, I remember what I ugh. I'm
failing at typing today.
Hey.
I don't know if that's even right. Okay.
So
and by default, we're using a
password based encryption, which means any secret site
access project relevant to get repository and correct
people with that password. It does also connect
to cloud service KMSs and to Vault. So
if I really wanted to make this a
bit more secure, I could say, go speak
to this Vault server, get a a management
key, or go speak to GCP,
KMS, AWS, KMS, or even Azure KMS. Yep.
That's nice.
Yeah. Let me it's cool. Although I do
I know it's one of these really superficial
things. It does bother me that the index
dot t s gets created in the root
directory.
I I don't think that. But You you
want to that.
Not gonna let that stop us. Right? Yeah.
No. No. I'm gonna pick it. So I'm
just gonna create a source folder. I'm gonna
go pull in here. And the only thing
I need to change
is
main
source
and that
k.
Cancel.
Okay. So
we're now in a position where we can
create a server.
Yeah.
That's good.
Okay. So
this should have installed the SDK for me,
which means I should already get all complete.
I'm gonna confirm that first.
What we is this like a a management
server I need to create first? Do we
need more than one server?
We'll need a a
master node and a worker nodes or so
let's let's have two in total. We can
have one and do everything on there, but
it's more interesting if we have two because
then we can demonstrate that networking across nodes
actually works, and I'm not bluffing.
So let's do two. Yeah.
We can maybe let's do
so you want to make one,
like, where the control plane is gonna run,
like the cube control plane, and then
some workers.
Got it. So that's a
our admin server, which I'm just gonna call
admin.
And it's a few required properties.
So so we'll
go over it onto that.
We will need
okay.
Are you typing, or you're just trying to
trip me up? Is that what it is?
No. No. I'm I'm not touching the keyboard
at all. No.
And we get all complete on the operating
system. It should be possible.
So let's go with the good two eighteen
o four.
So our newer versions, but I think the
provider
doesn't have all the list yet. Mhmm. Yep.
Okay. So we do need a project ID.
Let's put that as a question mark. We'll
need to bring that to a configuration.
Yep. And we need a
plan.
And
is there any minimum sizes that I'm gonna
require here? So I've been using the the
the old t one micros,
which I don't know if they're even I
can still spawn them up, but they are
not in the list anymore by default. So
just the smallest thing, it's fine. There's no
you know? Okay. I'm gonna start with c
two medium. Okay. What else does it require?
So it's telling me
I need a balance cycle, and my facility
shouldn't be
where are you? Let's see.
Oh, I lost connection.
Wait. Reconnect.
Let's see. Hopefully, we're okay.
Okay. So let's do balance cycle.
We'll do monthly.
I think that should be. I'm not sure
why that's.
What am I missing now? So I'm gonna
type facility.
Host name is missing. Okay.
Yep. We need a host name. Yes. Alright.
Just admin. Admin. Yep.
Oh, the red squiggles are gone. That that's
a good thing.
Cool.
So the project ID is currently
lacking,
plus we also need to
tell this
oh, we need to configure the organization. So
the two setup pieces that we have to
do.
So first,
let me config set.
Let's do project
ID.
And I can grab this value, which is
not a secret.
So
you pre created a a packet project. Right?
It's a
Correct.
Yep. I don't believe I need the organization
ID, but I will add it just in
case.
And we need one secret
as our off
And that just gets namespace as
accurate, I believe.
And it will get it from your secrets
file automatically.
Or how does this work?
I'm gonna paste the end while no one
is looking at me.
So if I just hit return here,
pop over here,
and same file.
I'm
still getting used to this Mac nonsense.
Okay. There is my API token. Oh, if
I have opened, it's gonna open it. It's
that's good.
Hey.
And clutter clutter.
And you okay.
And then because this is a secret, we
could write a password, encrypts it,
and if we we don't need to see
view. If we open our production configuration, here's
what we have.
So Uh-huh.
We have two project specific
configuration options, project ID and organization ID.
And we have a packet provider configuration where
we're off token, which is nicely encrypted with
my super secret password.
Perfect.
I hope. So
do I need to provide organization?
It does not appear like I do.
Also, the port ID is enough with my
AI token.
I think
we're almost in a position to test this.
But first, we need to
add our config.
Here.
And then replace our credit ID here.
This is going to be require,
and we told it reject
ID.
And the moment of truth.
Let's see.
And now you forgot the pass phrase. Right?
I have not forgot the password. There we
go. Okay. Alright.
Well, we haven't really allocated any user data
here. I'm assuming we actually want this machine
to do something. Right?
Yep. No? But well so
do you want to
do all this stuff through a user data
file, or do we just want to SSH
into it and
go through the process manually?
I
think that it's better to do it manually
because we'll probably make some mistakes. And if
we have to wait every time to reprovision
a machine, if we change the user data,
it might be a bit
slow. So we we we we can act
as if
as if we're doing this all the correct
way, but we'll just SSH into the box
and do stuff there, I think.
Okay. So as we SSH and do stuff,
I will just update something locally in our
repository, and then when I publish this online,
it will be fine. Yep. Yep. So saying
that my balance cycle must be one of
error rate.
If I changed it to error rate.
Yeah. I actually do also have a reference
repository I can share afterwards, which sets this
up on the flat core Linux with some
user data.
So if people want to run a demo
from scratch at home, then it should it
should work.
Okay. I will try this one more time
and assume that we're just syncing my changes
remotely because we are using a remote dot
payment.
Now that that's our label, it works. That
looks much better. Okay. So we have a
machine spinning up. Yep.
So we have not
tweaked the networking configuration of this machine. So
that means that by default, we are going
to get a machine that has
two I p v four addresses and two
I p v six addresses, I believe.
One I p v six address, actually. One.
Yeah. One. Yeah. Because so we will get
a private I p v four and a
public I p v four,
and we will only get one I p
v six because there is no such thing
as well, there is such a thing as
private I p v six, but it's highly
unusual to use.
So and
one thing that you'll also see in the
packet project is that
not only did we get an IPv6 address
for the box,
in the project itself,
under Networks
Yes, under IPs,
we'll see that we now have a public
IPv6 block
allocated
to our project.
And this has
trillions
of IP addresses. So it's two to the
power 72
IP addresses that we got assigned.
And
we will use this later because we'll use
this block also to allocate IP addresses for
our pods. So not only for the nodes
that we create on packets, which will which
packet will
do automatically,
we'll also do it for the pods.
So
can we have data sources in
Pulumi?
I want to get this I p v
six block into our config because we're gonna
need it.
This is something we can do. Yes. We
can do that. We have we we have
access
to
yeah. We can use data sources. It's the
same way Terraform which is in. Mhmm. Definitely.
Yep.
So we can either copy paste this block
and or we can use a data source
to retrieve it, and then whatever
you think is cooler.
Okay. Let's start as a conflict right now,
and we'll see how we're doing for time.
And I can always, you know, clean this
up later. I'm I wanna let's we'll focus
on the Kubernetes IPv6 steps. Yeah. Exactly.
So
let's just split this term.
And
configs
the IPv6.
Exactly.
K. So that's just gonna take
I've been to eighteen o four as one
of the fast provision boxes. I would expect
this to take maybe around two minutes, maybe
three work case.
We look at the progress. We can actually
see it's just rebooted, and it's gonna put
on hold. So it's actually always done.
Yep. Cool. I I Okay. The other thing
I did do was
enable BGP
on this project. So we do have BGP
set up.
Yep.
So there's also so just for the record,
we're going to use
Calico, which is a CNI provider that integrates
with
BGP.
And for the listener, BGP is a protocol
you can use to talk to your router
in your data center to announce
routes.
And what we will do is,
and we'll also see this update in this
window later, is we'll announce where pods are
in our data center. So, we can tell
the
routers and packets this pod is running on
that node. So, if you get a request
to this pod, send it to this node
in the cluster.
And this way, all the pods can find
each other. The pod will
send the requests out to another pod. It
will go through the packet router and then
to the node that has it.
And we'll use BGP for that.
One thing that we'll have to set up
also in is
we will have to tell packets that this
server that we created is going to talk
to the router.
And
in
TerraForm, this resource is called let me peek
Packet BGP session.
So we'll have to create a packet BGP
session which
associates
the device with the packet router.
K. So Yep. BGP session
for new
packet
BGP session. Exactly.
And this is our admin this is our
publisher for publishing works. Is that Yep. Right.
Okay.
So
what do we need here?
I think a address family and a device
ID are the two things that we'll need.
So this will be
IPV6,
and then the device ID is the server
admin.
Yep.
I would be
Exactly.
Send Do we also
we already want to create a
a worker device as well? We can just
copy paste this code and bring it and
set host name to worker.
So
there we are. Worker.
Worker
one.
Worker one.
Mhmm. Is that it?
Yep. And then also create a BGP session
for it because we also need it.
Okay.
So do we
right.
One
I I I always had too much time
on the political stuff. But because we need
to do that repeatedly
Yep. What what we can do is if
we grab this,
make this a function.
Yeah. Which returns a new server.
And then here, we see create server,
and we'll inject
our
name
with string.
Why are you to print?
Oops. Sorry. What's the multiple string types?
Host name, which I guess we can just
make the name of the server.
Mhmm. That makes sense.
That's
it. Right?
Yep.
From here, I can I want to be
able to reuse that resource? I'm just gonna
pull the admin and not change that. Okay?
Mhmm.
We will then
I never remember. I lost the person working
on that.
Anyway, server
worker one,
server
worker two.
And are the BGP sessions the same for
all of these?
Yeah. So there will always be address family
I p v six and then the device
ID. Yeah. And this
is just so that the packet routers know
that these servers might announce routes to the
router. Otherwise, it will reject
will reject all the BGP traffic.
So
Perfect.
You
will have this return,
a JavaScript object,
which now has a BGP session.
Yep.
We'll give it a
name and then
It's like enter an internal reference.
Put that in a variable. Yes.
If I would smart, I would have called
it device.
Oh, yeah. Think I'm gonna use this fancy
JavaScript syntax.
Yeah. There we go.
We were refactoring our code. So now we
have a function that creates a server and
the BGP session,
and then we create the three devices and
the three BGP sessions. Yep. Sounds good.
So let's just apply that, and then we
can already start on the admin node and
configure some stuff.
Perfect. So if I put pulling me up.
Password.
K.
Five to create I'm hoping that's when I
realized it's wrong.
Yeah. Well, you would expect it to
Well, it's only it's not creating the the
device.
Right? That's good. Yeah. It's only creating the
speech to speech session. Okay. Good. Perfect. Oh,
yeah. Two unchanged.
Yep. Alright.
So let's
jump on to our admin.
I never thought of this part.
I would do this for iTerm. I don't
think my key is gonna be passed through,
but let's check.
Uh-huh.
Right. Three.
Put your font. Alright. That's the page. Yeah.
Now I have access to my YubiKey.
We're in. We're in. K. So
we're gonna use Kube ADM to
bootstrap a Kubernetes cluster. Have you used Kube
ADM before?
Not in three or four years.
Okay.
So
it is not too complicated.
Usually, it's just you type kubeadm in it,
that's all you have to do. But of
course, because we're running IPv6,
we need to tweak some configures some configurations.
So we just need to install kubeadm
and the
kubelet so that we can
bootstrap things.
Oops. I'm working.
So then
so it seems pseudo, but we're running a
group.
Are there any more pseudos here?
Yep. There's still a pseudo apt key.
Yep. Perfect.
Yeah. And this is obvious obviously something we
would add to our user data usually because
we'll have to run it on every box.
I'm going to I'm
going to cheat a little bit and give
you a kubeadm config
instead of us reconstructing
it from scratch.
If it's on your repository,
what I could always browse to it?
Yep. So it is in my repository, but
it's templated. But that and we'll have to
fill in your IP addresses.
I should have just used the Terraform, but
we'll we'll keep it. No. No. It's fine.
I I have plenty of time. It's okay.
I will send you a link.
Let's shall I share it through the
Yeah. This is the private chat.
Put I've put it in a comment in
the index dot t s.
Ah, I'd save. K.
So you'll
see a
a kube a d m slash config dot
yaml
Yep.
Which contains everything we need. So
if you just copy paste that into a
file, and then we can fill in the
blanks.
Okay. So what is this call it?
No.
I'll keep it at the end of config.
So in fact, highlight in there, I think.
No. It's YAML, obviously. YAML. Yep.
So Something different is that isn't YAML or
is that sync? Yeah. So So this is
an Ignition config, and we only need the
cube ADM part of this. So we can
remove a whole bunch of things. So this
is basically a the user data of a
of my flat core Linux device. So if
I will
let's see. I'll just open the window as
well, and then I can edit. Right?
Mhmm.
Okay.
It's loading. Come on.
It won't load.
Live share is cool when it works.
So if you just
if I just close it and reopen it,
you'll get popped into it anyway. So let's
do that.
Nope.
It seems to be sort of disconnected
somehow.
It's it's still convinced that you're editing the
index of t s. This is
but yeah.
If you scroll all the way down this
file,
you'll see a
little bit up.
You'll see this cube yeah. Down. No. No.
No. More down. More down. Yeah.
Kube a d m slash config dot yaml.
And this is the only content that we
need. So
so there's a the the contents of that
file is the only thing we need. So
we can remove all the other stuff in
this file.
Just copy that out. Yeah. Exactly.
And we just want this available on each
of our notes. Right?
Yep.
And we will have to and we'll have
to edit some place some things,
some placeholders.
So, the certificate key and bootstrap token, can
just remove. We don't need them.
When you leave them out, kubeadm will come
up with default values. So, we can just
delete those.
Then there is
the node IP, which needs to be the
the I p v six address of our
node.
Okay. So is that our admin node?
Yep.
So if we go into details,
we will see the IPv6 address.
Yes, that's it.
Okay. Good.
And then we'll have the control plane endpoint,
which will also be the IP address
of this node.
And then
the
then we will have to come up with
two
IP subnets
for our service range and our pod subnet.
So this is where our virtual IPs will
live and in which range our pods will
live.
We don't want to this to clash with
nodes that Packet creates automatically.
So
what we're going to do is just
copy paste your the IP address you just
had into both.
Okay. Remove the three in both cases.
Okay.
And the service subnet, we will make D001.
So you see the D00?
I got you. Oh, yeah. And then just
leave the yes. And then we'll do a
at
the end.
So
this basically means that
we will allocate
all the service IPs will be prefixed with
this part, and we need to do 108
because we can only have 1,000,000
service IP addresses in a Kubernetes cluster. It's
some hard limits. If you change this number
to something that is normal in IPv6,
because usually, you assign 64
per range. Kubernetes will actually crash. I found
this out the hard way. This is not
documented anywhere.
108 is the magic number that we need.
Don't ask too many questions.
And then the POD subnet will make d00
will make it two and then 64.
Yes. So
this means that we
expect all our pods to get assigned to
public IP address, which is what we want.
Right?
So, yeah, we can put this in a
config dot YAML, which we copy over to
the box.
Yep.
Is it
if you disable the page for mounting.
Oh, yeah. Set based or something. Right?
Yeah. I think they're right.
And then we want to and indent this
a bit.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah. Let's just do it that way. Yeah.
That's good.
Right there. Okay. Yep. So let's save this.
And now
we're gonna type.
Okay.
So, there are a few things that we
need to make sure before we can initialize
the cluster.
First is that we have a DNS server
in etcresolveconf
that is an IPv6 address. The reason for
that is our pods will only have
IPv6
addresses,
and they won't be able to resolve external
traffic if this is an IPv4 address. So
we can
pick one.
If you go back to that file,
I think it's in here. So oh, no.
Wait. It's not. Wait.
So we can, I don't know, take the
the Google servers or something?
I will
Alright. I'll just
I'll put it.
Yeah. Exactly.
There
it is. Yep.
So let's put these in Etsy Resolve
and replace those two at the top.
We can keep one IPv4 one in there,
actually, because otherwise,
other stuff will get angry.
So,
yes, exactly.
Perfect.
Okay. So now we can do
sudo kubeadm
init
dash dash config
and then your config file.
And it will run a bunch of preflight
checks that will tell us things that are
not configured correctly on our box yet.
We might have to set up a forwarding
rule in the kernel or something, or Docker
isn't started yet.
So,
yes. No Docker.
So, let's apt install docker.io.
You suddenly start to appreciate
these managed Kubernetes services. Right? It's like
Yeah. I I used to work for a
company that runs, like, a a tender competitor
in Europe, and we managed all of their
Kubernetes clusters of bare metal. Mhmm.
It was fun and challenging at the same
time.
So what is it angry about now? Oh,
yeah. We need to disable yeah. It we
will have to disable swap.
So just swap swap off.
Oh, yeah. Enable docker is also useful.
And then I always forget what you need
to type here.
STP2.
Okay. Yes, perfect.
So yes,
and we need to set
proxies net IPv6
config default forwarding
to one.
The reason for this is we're going to
receive
requests from other nodes trying to reach a
Pod IP, right?
And our server isn't listening on any Pod
IPs. It's the Pods themselves that are listening
on the Pod IPs. So if it receives
an IP address that it doesn't know, it
needs to forward it
to one of the pods on the box.
So we have to set up IP forwarding
for this.
Yeah. I was trying to look at why
that exists, but I just I I forgot
the view. Okay. So I think we're now
all set, and we can start bootstrapping it.
Okay. Let's
try that again.
Okay.
So, yeah, this will take a minute or
two, plus it downloads all the
required components,
or it will crash halfway through because we
forgot something.
In the static manifest.
Yep. And now
so now it's gonna be pulling the energies
for each of those
those static manifests. Okay. Yep.
And it will actually print out instructions how
we bootstrap our worker notes.
So don't
I knew you would do that. You'd always
tell me you do this. Right? Just control
l. So scroll up a bit. There's important
information that we need.
There is. But I I was wondering whether
I really want people to be able to
join my cluster.
Yes. It's okay with well, this So yeah.
So first of all, we can download the
kube config.
That's useful, I guess. So that's the very
first step.
So the kube config for this cluster is
in at ckubernetesadmin.com,
and we can copy it from the box
to your management note if you want to,
so that we have kubectl working.
We can already see if that works.
So if you would do kubectl get nodes,
see if it works, and then
let's copy that.
So yes, As you can see, the node
is in a not ready state because that's
because we haven't installed a CNI plug in
yet. So there's no networking setup yet.
But we'll get to that
very soon.
Do you just want to do it from
the master node?
Because we have ibv6 connectivity here as well,
so it's
nice and easy.
So we're going to install
Calico.
Shall I just send you a link to
the comments that you'll have to type?
Yeah. Go for it. Yep.
So
we will need the following two things.
Where are you?
It would be nice if we can get
the share terminal up again. Do we want
to try and see if we can get
the live share to work?
Can you
do you see me type in index dot
t s now?
I do. Yes. Okay.
So
You should be able to type in my
terminal, which is on the working note. Do
you want me to
Is that is that okay to do the
commands there? Or or no? We need the
config. Right? Yeah. Yeah. So We we will
need the cube config there, though, so the
cube CTL works. That's all.
So
yep.
Exports
cube config equals cube config.
I need the full path here. Right? I
think. No. You can just do dot slash.
Oh, okay.
There we go. That's nice. K. So we're
now gonna
copy.
I
accidentally did something.
What did I do?
I created a new terminal.
Oh, okay. Excellent.
That still works. Okay.
Pasting is a bit funky here.
I believe I'm using KubeCTL
create after my Twitter run about people using
KubeCTL
create.
Instead instead of apply?
Yeah.
Run for another day. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Then
we are going to
get
installed. So this so Calico has an
operator
to manage Calico, which is kind of neat.
And then
I will make a new file here.
Oh, control N opens a new browser tab.
Let's see how
I will press
this.
For some reason, it doesn't like me changing
files.
It just doesn't work in live share.
So the terminal works fine.
So
So there's some oh, sometimes yeah. I've had
that before in live share sessions too. There's
a little, like, reload. I don't know if
you can see my screen right now. But
if you press that, it generally kinda kicks
it,
the refresh explorer button.
Where is this button?
So on the sidebar about the files and
directories, there's, four icons,
and then there's, like, a wee circle with
an arrow on it, and that generally just
kicks it to refresh the file system cache.
No. If I open a file, it just
gives me a loading
screen.
So I'll have to guide you in typing.
This is Okay. I can I can do
this? I can do it. Yes. Okay.
So
let's
go to
I'll give you a link, and then I'll
tell you to try it yourself. This is
always fun.
Let's see what the link is.
So is this on your GitHub stuff? Can
I get it from there?
Yep. Definitely.
Alright. So
top level, I go and say
You can go to ignitionmaster.jamo.
Got it. And we're gonna copy and I'll
scroll all the way to the bottom,
and you will see a Calico config. We're
gonna copy paste that.
So
I actually just noticed this flex volume path
thing.
You might have to so
this is only needed
on
FlatCar Linux because, by default, it tries to
install FlexVolume plug ins in user
lib exec,
but that doesn't exist on FlatCar.
The thing is we also configured our
control plane to use this path, I think,
in our kubeadm config. Can you double check
that?
Because we might have to remove that part.
Like that.
Yeah.
So this it might be that the cube
the it starts complaining about this path. So
we could quickly
try and Yeah. Just try and.
Yep. So if we go back to your
terminal
and we edit the config
first.
Yes.
And we remove those extra arcs.
So,
yeah, both there and also in the cluster
configuration.
Yep.
Exactly. And then you can do kubeadm reset.
And then without the config. So, first, we
do reset and then we reinstall again. So,
we just do reset.
Okay. And then we want to run NA
again.
Exactly.
K.
Okay.
And
then we want to That's just on the
machine. Right? Yep.
And we also want to now cube key
do the cube cuddle create or apply again.
What about the first command,
the command? I see that here, actually.
Yes. It's in here. Exactly. Yep.
So we can run this.
Mhmm.
Oh. Make config. Okay. Yeah. You have to
copy the kube config again because we now
have new certificates. Right? So so
oh, it it copies in interactively.
So it refuses to override it because there's
a c p dash I.
Of course.
So
Okay, good.
And now we look at this calico file
that you have.
And it's different from the one they ship
by default.
So we will have to change one thing
here. The interface
is not is I think it's bond zero
in your case as well. Could you make
sure that it is?
It is. Good.
So I disable ibv4 detection,
and I enable ibv6 detection.
And this is just so that Calico
configures itself as a ibv4,
ibv6.
And this by default, it does I p
v four with an overlay network, a la
Flannel.
But if you have this option, it will
use I p v six instead.
Okay. So I think if you
based on oh, I probably got by mistake.
But I can paste in cube CTL,
the eight
point No. My calendar file. No? Yes.
Yes.
Sure. You said no. I wanted to say
no, but it's yes. Yep.
Hello. Yep. So now if we do
kubectl
get no
gets let's get all pods. We'll see
that it's creating some stuff.
Alright.
Yeah. That will take yeah. It will take
a little while for the Calico to come
up.
Okay. Nice. So And then what we did
there was we installed
the operator.
And then based on the Calico.YAML
fail here,
it's determined that we need
these parts. Right? Yep. Exactly. Yeah. Okay.
And
so
the the the Calico cube controller will listen
to network policies that you define and configure
firewall rules.
And the Calico node is what we call
a BGP speaker. So what it will do
is it will after we set it up,
we haven't done it yet, it will talk
to your router, to your gateway,
and it will announce so Calico node will
run on each node in your cluster. And
it will say, I have these pods, they
have these IPs,
and they are on this node. So it
will say,
pod NGINX1
is
on my node. So if you see the
pod IP of NGINX1,
you have to route it to me, and
I will give you the answer.
So
once this is all initialized, can you check
if it's up yet?
Of
Yep.
Very good. Yeah. So and if you do
kubectl get node, it should say ready.
Okay.
So let's create a
an NGINX deployment.
Let's just
create some pods on this.
Well, we'll have to remove the taint from
the from the control plane node.
We or do we want to spin up
a worker first?
We can do either.
Yep.
What about the what about the thing? I
mean, we can add the worker.
Yep.
K.
And we want to create
I don't know. Run kind of x.
Yeah. Test dash test dash image.
Yes.
K.
K. So the image is coming.
And let's see if it gets assigned an
IP address.
Can you do dash o wide?
And we can get
Okay.
So we see now our pod has a
public IP address.
However
okay. We should be able to reach it
from this node. So if you curl it,
it should work.
So we have to put it between brackets,
the IP address,
square brackets.
We should be able to get yeah, that
works.
However, if we try to run it from
any of the other nodes,
which we don't have well, we have them.
Or from the outside, we will not have
a route to
this node because there's no way for other
people to know that this pod is running
on this node.
This is where yeah.
Let's jump on to worker one then.
Yep.
So we have our admin mode on the
top. I'm gonna have to fix it. I
have to fix it.
We have a key. Okay. So if we
copy this curl command, you're saying that's what
fail and that's because we are not advertising
this address. Right? Yeah.
You missed the square brackets.
So nothing happens. Right? There's no route.
So now what we're going to do is
we're going to
teach Calico
about how the network infrastructure of Packet looks
like.
What Packet looks like is
every node,
every device that you create will also have
a gateway address. You can also see this
in your Packet's in the
Packet's
screen. And the gateway is the address of
the router you talk to.
And this means we'll have to tell this
address,
hey, these pods exist, and they
reside on me, and I
will
be able to resolve this IP address for
you. And this we do through BGP.
So we'll set up a BGP session between
Calico node pod
and the packet router, and it will then
start telling the packet router, I have these
pods. You can contact me for this pod.
So that will be the next part of
our party trick, I guess.
We can again go into my repository.
And you will see a file called bgp
peer. Yaml.
Yep. Yes.
And it's templated, so we'll have to fill
it in a bit. So the first step
is the BGP configuration,
which we can copy paste.
K.
And this will have to apply with Calico
CTL instead of kubectl,
by the way.
K.
Alright.
Yep. Yep. I go.
Mhmm.
There we go. Okay. So we want our
server side.
Okay. So let's leave
that out for now.
This will set up later.
We can just remove those two fields.
I will we'll we're gonna edit this file
later and reintroduce them as a party trick,
but we won't need them for now. So
you can just comment them out.
So
let's just
take in what this all says. So
what Kali code does by default, if you
install it on an I p v four
network, it will create an overlay network,
and
it will use BGP as well, but in
a node to node mesh, as we call
it. So
every node will talk to every node and
use BGP to tell each other, I have
these pods. So it's like a a mesh
network.
So node a will tell, I have the
NGINX pods. Node b will tell, I have
the, I don't know, the Alpine pods.
And
but we don't want this behavior because
we have a router packet at the top
of a rack, and we can just tell
the router where the routes are. So we're
going to disable the node to node mesh
by setting node to node mesh enabled false.
And then we're going to
later configure
Kali code to directly talk to the router.
And so this means that all the traffic
will be reflected through the router from nodes
to the other nodes
instead of going through an overlay network.
And this this is also the reason why
we don't need to have some kind of
overlay network, but we can just use a
flat address space because we can bounce off
all the routes between the pods
through the packet routers.
So this is why we have this node
to node mesh enabled false. It's enabled through
by default, so we set it to false.
So can we apply this configuration
using Calico CTL?
We can try, but Oh, yeah. Wait.
Yeah. We have to do two things first.
We have to explicitly
set the kubeconfig
environment variable because otherwise, calico gets angry.
And then we set this to your KubeConfig
path.
I think that's already set because we can
do
it.
Yes. But
And
we have to set export datastoretype
equals Kubernetes.
This is because Calico can run-in two modes.
You can either store all the networking information
in etcd directly.
And this is because you can also use
Calico on non Kubernetes nodes to handle routing.
Or you can store it in Kubernetes directly,
and we'll use custom resource definitions to store
everything.
Oh, cool. Okay. Yep.
So Now I can run c
t l apply f
and then our file.
Yep.
Oh,
I'm sure I installed you.
I did so too. I saw you install
it.
Oh, maybe not on the admin no. Not
on the admin notes. We installed it on
your
the other box. Yep.
K. So, Carol,
not
Hey.
Cool.
Okay.
So now we're gonna set up
Calico to talk to the packet router. So
if we go back to my file, you
will see a BGP peer file,
BGP peer snippet. Just copy one of them.
Yes.
We don't need the the template stuff. Just
yep. That's enough. Yep. So
I have a little template that generates it
for every node in your packet project.
So this will be the the host name,
admin.
Then this will be the address of the
packet router,
which we can look up in
And of course, if we did this all
nicely, we would do this with Pulumi and
get the attribute out and then link it
all in. But this I'll leave this as
some
if you can send a PR to my
projects to convert it to Pulumi, I will
accept it.
So if you go to the admin node
I will definitely automate all of this. No
problem. Yeah. So you will should see the
gateway. Yeah. It's okay. Right? Yeah.
And then this AS number, this is
so
this is how each router identifies itself in
BGP as I understand it. People now say,
you don't know how this works. I don't
know how this works. I just tried it
out and it worked.
And
so this is the the identifying number of
the packet router.
As long as you didn't select
enable passwords when you set up your packet
projects, this should be enough. Otherwise, we also
need to provide the password of the router.
But I don't think you did that. Right?
No. No password. We are in the middle.
Yep. And the last field is a node
selector. So this will
and and usually, when you have our on
prem, you will have one router, and many
nodes will be
talking to this router. Right?
In in the packet clouds, each node gets
assigned its own
distinct public gateway. But usually, you'll have, I
don't know, 20 nodes talking to the same
public gateway. And this way, you so you
can use a node selector syntax here to,
for example, say, all nodes should talk to
this router,
or, I don't know, all nodes in Rack
1 should should talk to router a, and
all nodes in Rack 2 should talk to
router b. And this way, you can describe
what your topology looks like in your data
center.
But in the case of packets, every node
has its own router, and it talks to
it individually.
So we'll have to create a BGP peer
object per nodes that we add.
So
any questions about this or things
that are unclear?
No. I think that makes sense. So we're
just we're telling this
yeah.
You're saying if if we add worker one
and two, if we decide to design that
work, then we would just duplicate the style,
changing the node here. Right? The node name.
Yep. Yeah. And the peer IP
also.
Because every node will talk to a different
gateway address in packets.
So if we apply this
Okay.
Can you now type sudo oh, no. Yeah,
calico
node status.
Calico CTL node status.
So now we can see that it has
established a connection with the
routers at Packet
and that this connection is up.
And this should mean that Calico is now
announcing where all our pods are. So if
we now go to
our
if we now curl it, it should work,
I think.
It has woo.
And if it will even work from my
computer. So if if we want to do
a party trick, you can send me the
link to the pod
in the chat and
Here.
And if I go to it
You can share your screen too if you
wish, you wanna show it off.
Yeah. So let's share my screen.
Okay. I'm sharing my screen.
Yeah. We're now switched over. Here we go.
Look at this. There we go.
All the way from a pod in your
network through the packet routers to my house
in Germany
with no overlay networks.
Okay. That's pretty cool. That's pretty cool. Right?
Yeah. Yeah. I'm impressed.
Okay. So
do we want to add another node to
our cluster?
Because the next cool party trick that we
could do, if you want, if you still
have time,
is we can set up some load balancing
and have a service that we can expose
to the outside world.
Yeah. I definitely wanna see this this service
stuff. So let's let's do that then. Yep.
So but, yeah, we can do it with
one note, but it's not that interesting. With
two notes, I think it's it's cooler. Right?
So
if you We
need our
k. Maybe the end. Right?
Yeah. But we're gonna write a join configuration
instead of an in its configuration.
But you can find that again in my
repository.
So
You've done all the hard work. I don't
have to.
Exactly. So
you can find this
over there. Yep. Perfect.
Alright. So I'm gonna
paste this, like, the code
and move presentation again.
Mhmm.
Close that.
I'm back over to my terminal, and we
will create a content
panel.
We can remove this.
Yeah. And what did you remove just now?
Wait. Can you I think we removed too
much. No. Yeah. That that we can remove.
Yes. Correct.
Good.
That syntax is a bit weird. Right? Yeah.
Certificates key can go and control plane can
go as well.
Yep.
We can move the volume that we don't
need, and then we need to add our
address. Right? Mhmm.
Yeah. So this is the address. Very
good.
Okay. So Worker
1, the B C P 6 address.
But we are on Worker 0. Right? It's
not Worker 1,
are we?
No. We're on Worker 1. Okay. Good. There
there is no Worker 0 because it wasn't
automated.
Well, it was automated, but I didn't add
an increment on the tenth or anything. Yeah.
How do I get the join token again?
So with the print
Yeah. There is some print command for this
to get a new one. Yes.
I think it's
cube a d m
token generates.
No.
This will just generate I
think we need to No.
Great. There we go. Yeah. But that just
generates a token. It doesn't store it. So
that's not enough.
Should I just follow-up and find the first
one? Yeah. And otherwise, we need to rerun
a certain part of the interface.
Eight.
Kubeadm
generates new
Okay. Token. I will just ask You
found it?
Yeah. Yep. Yep. Okay. So we will
have to set so
we can do the token
and set it.
If we are good citizens, we also set
the discovery token c a cert hash.
But I just have unsafe
skip CA verification now. That also works. It's
not completely unsafe.
So it's
only unsafe
if somebody
knows what your Bootstrap token is. So if
that leaks, then somebody can impersonate the control
plane.
But
we can just skip it for now. It's
not like anybody can see this token right
now, right, on the stream? Oh, wait.
But that's fine.
Yeah.
Okay. Anything else I have to change here?
No. I think that's it.
Oh, wait. I see a typo. One sec.
Open it again. First line. There's a space
too much.
Yep. Perfect.
So now we do kubeadm
join dash dash config.
Yeah. And
you can install it again, though.
Because we've always thought on it. I don't
know which.
Really?
I should have done the user data in
advance, but I will automate this. Yep. And
you'll also have to install Docker, disable swap,
and
set this
forwarding rule.
Got it. So stop Docker. Let's pull up
the echo
one command.
Exactly.
And I can manually do the other two
commands.
So
what's that? So we wanna do with this
control, docker, and enable
docker service,
swap off. I'm assuming the device will be
the same.
It was too. Was too. Yep. Echo.
Got it. Yep.
And I can do it. Be the end
join onto
convo dot level. Mhmm.
Copy that.
And, no, wait. I did run this. Right?
Yeah.
At
install. Oh, no.
Install.
I'll just run all of them. Maybe it
got confused because of sudo again.
Or no? Oh, well
okay. You wanted to
Yeah. This is working.
Oh, maybe I didn't know that. Oh, no.
I installed Docker. Ah. Mhmm.
So let's just confirm what I called the
local config,
config dot YAML, the BDM join config.
K.
Unknown field bootstrap token. Interesting.
Oh, it needs to be indented once.
Yeah. Bootstrap token needs to indent. And then
let's see. I think we made some
a little typo there.
What does it look like?
Oh, yeah. It's good like this. Yep.
K.
K. So up here, I'm just gonna run
the that notes.
Hey. It's worker one. Yeah. It's not ready
currently because it's still starting up
the
Calico nodes, probably, the daemon.
So it runs this as a daemon sets
on each node,
and it will take a little while to
come up.
K. We can try that with a watch,
wait for the sales to change. Yep. So
what we're gonna do now is we're gonna
run
multiple engine x pods, expose them with a
service IP, and use that to do load
balancing. Is that correct? Yep. Exactly.
So let's first delete our NGINX pods and
create a deployment instead
so we can
so we can do
create
deployment, and then we do, I don't know,
replicas 10 or something.
I'm really looking forward to that new generator
on this kind of oh,
I run engine x, and then it's engine
x, right, both. Right.
Yep. And now we can do
and hope and if we do a wide,
we'll see that they get scheduled,
hopefully, across the cluster.
Yep.
And we just wait on two more.
Yeah. So you'll need to download the image
on the other node,
probably. Or
I'm gonna see the watch one and then
stop the installation.
But do we still need to when we
were looking at the
Kalicool,
we need to add our BGP here. Is
that right?
Yep. Exactly.
But
we so we'll also have to add the
worker one. Yep. So
we can just add another element to the
list.
Yeah. I think that's essential.
And and this, of course,
again,
smells like templating and automation.
But
So
need
it's IP address, but also the gateway. So
Oh, only the gateway you need. Only the
gateway. Okay. Yeah.
It's four.
K.
We
can apply
this.
Yeah. And now on the worker, we can
do
Calico CTO status
node status. So the thing is you have
to run this
on the node itself because it talks
to the BIRT daemon directly that's running.
So BIRT is
the daemon that runs inside the calico node
pods that acts that talks to
router.
Okay.
Look at this. It's not healthy.
Let's look
at the pods in the
Caliper system.
The images?
I don't know.
But something is off.
So
we're still waiting on so that's not what
I don't think is healthy yet. Right? Yeah.
So
there are a few
can you look at the
pods in the Calico system
namespace?
Are they all running? So there's one crashing.
You see?
It has been it has crashed five times
in the past three minutes, so it's not
very healthy.
Yeah. Both the worker one parts are failing.
So let's grab the logs.
Yeah. Let's see what's up.
Is where we go off script.
Oh, the namespace.
Yep.
K.
What is the error?
It says successfully loading to config.
I think it crashed. Yeah.
Can you look at the Calico note one?
The typhob
part is less interesting.
I don't even know what it does, I
think.
So let's do a
right.
Bring that. That shouldn't be on it from
there.
Ah. Failing.
Or it's not ready.
Okay.
But why not?
Oh,
look at this.
No such
file directory node name. Oh, we didn't modify
the result.com.
That might be
related,
but not sure.
But
Mhmm. And we also have an error here
saying that says node name failed just like
this.
Yeah.
This is all a bit suspect.
Yeah. Directories.
Yeah.
I'm not sure if this is a directory
inside the
pod, the thing or not. K. Can
No pressure.
Can we look at the logs one more
time?
Maybe it tells more now.
I
may have to delete it at the store
and fresher back up.
And catch it quickly.
I
think you know we're now looking at the
wrong one.
This is the healthy one, I think.
We need to
have the one on worker one.
I see what's going on.
You see the IP
address?
Oh, no. Wait. That's okay. Never mind. Yeah.
There's something fishy here.
And why is it got an IP v
four address? Exactly.
So
I think I know what we did wrong.
You say we, but you mean me. Right?
Well, no. We we together.
Can
you
okay. Yep.
So this usually means
so we have to, in our kube ad
m config, tell
the worker what their IP address is. If
you don't do this, it will
we did this. No.
Because I was going to update this, and
you told me we didn't have to. So
it was your fault. Oh, but it is.
It is.
Interesting.
Let me think. But, yeah, something is going
wrong there, and it's auto detecting the wrong
IP address. And this is why it isn't
healthy.
Can we do a QVDM reset on that
node? Yeah. Like this?
We can.
But you will have to kubectl delete notes
manually from a
Yep. Afterwards.
K. Now
shall
we
where's my BGP?
Oh, no. We don't want the panel yet.
Okay.
Shall we just try this again then?
Yeah. Let's just try it again. I'm a
bit confused,
but it's okay.
Oh, you see? I see the error at
the top. There we go. Unknown field, Kubelet
extra arcs.
Uh-huh.
It has to be oh, yeah. Add two
spaces in front of Kubelet, extra arcs. No.
Yeah.
No. No. No. It has to be inside
node registration.
So yes.
There you go.
So it didn't know what its IP was,
so we just assumed I p v four,
which is the wrong one. Right?
And then
and this is the part that's not in
the documentation, by the way. I I had
to figure this out
the same way as we did now.
So,
like, nowhere does it say that you need
to set these fields on the cubelets. It
just says.
Yeah.
K. So
now it should be in a better state.
Let's just take a look at part of
the system.
K. There we go.
That looks better. Right? It does.
So if I run and get pods, I
should see all the engine x's now running,
and we should all have an I p
v six. Cool.
Yep.
And we have a service. Right?
So
did we already add the BGP peer for
this node? We did. Right?
We added a BGP peer for the admin
node. Yes. But
one thing we kept
empty was the service CIDR.
It's here.
Yeah. So I guess that seems to be
a little.
Yep. Yeah. But let's take one step back
first, though. Let's just first check everything. Can
you do Calico CTL
gets
BGP peer?
Just to make sure.
Yes, perfect.
Yes. So now comes
the cool part of the
of this thing.
Indeed, in BGP configuration, which you just opened,
we can also announce the service CIDR.
So now we're only announcing routes to our
pods
to the world,
but we can also announce
the cluster IPs of our cluster.
So we have to set this to the
same thing that we put in the
kube ADM in its configuration.
We'll see service Yes,
exactly.
Yes. And service external IPs, we can leave.
So you can this is useful. You can
also manually assign
external IPs to services if you want to.
And then they have to be out of
this range, and then Calico will also announce
them. But we don't need that for now.
So if we Calico
CTO apply this,
k. If you go to packets
to your packet console now,
and you go to network BGP,
and then
update status
and then refresh the page.
Here, we can see all the routes that
the nodes are telling to the package router.
So if we
click on worker one, for example, or admin,
you will see it is
announcing
the
service CIDR
and the pod CIDR.
So
the cool thing is, is that both worker
one and admin will announce the same service
block,
and this will cause
the packet routers to automatically load balance
between the two nodes. So you get a
a load balancer for free, basically.
So when the outside world says, I want
to reach a Kubernetes service, then the packet
router sees there's two entries for it. It's
either master or worker one,
and they will go to the queue proxy
of either of those, and then it will
go to the correct pod.
Yeah.
And you'll also see that the
pod CIDR
is different for each of the
so the server CIDR is the same because
we want to be able to load balance
this.
But the pod CIDR is different. So you
will have a subnet for all the pods
on the master node,
and you'll have a pod CIDR for all
the node for all the pods
on the
worker nodes, and they will be disjoint.
So this way, when you try to reach
a pod
Yeah. You see that they're different? This way,
the outside Internet knows how to route to
the correct node to reach the correct pod.
Yeah.
So Okay.
We can try this surface now that we
created.
We don't have one.
So Oh, yeah. We
So we can do
two CTL
expose.
Oh, yeah. I guess it's okay. Yeah. And
then NGINX.
Yeah.
Dash dash port 80,
and then I will just port.
Oh, yeah. Exposed deployment.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay. And now if we go and curl
this address, we should
get low balanced access to
to our NGINX service.
We could verify that by looking at the
the pot logs,
for example. But We can
change that.
So
image.
Options.
No. It's info.
Oh, what's this?
It's from the open fast protect, but it's
a function that returns information about the pod
that is running on over HTTP.
Cool.
So the port number might change, but I
can fix that. It looks like that's running.
Let's just run edit service.
And I
can never remember which way these are. So
80 eight is the target port.
There we go.
We have the host name. Cool.
Right? Alright. Is cool. I like it. Yeah.
But there's
so there's
one more thing that we can tweak. So
as you see
in the the routing table that we are
announcing to packets, we're announcing the entire service
range.
Yep.
Right? The whole. Right? Yep.
And
that's okay.
But sometimes,
there might be pods that are not running
on a on
worker zero, but are running on worker one.
But in this case, it will even contact
worker zero even though it's not running any
pods.
And it will then use kube proxy to
make this extra hop. So this is can
be
a bit detrimental for performance sometimes. So because
it will need an extra network hop to
reach the pod sometimes.
What it does do, it gives you very
equal load balancing, which is very nice. But
we can also configure Calico
to only advertise
nodes that actually is running a pod from
that service.
We can demonstrate this by maybe
making sure that there are only pods running
on one of the two nodes.
Yeah. And then we can show the difference
in in what happens with the routing tables.
So
Okay. So we want to
edit
node admin.
Let's add
but we can just.
We can just taint it again. Right?
Or some
Yeah. But we just do a copy and
paste in. No.
At the deployment.
Let's
do
anti affinity.
Officer.
Yeah. Come on. Just give me the don't
know.
Oh, yeah. This require during scheduling, ignore during
I always get very confused
by this stuff. So
let's grab
this
and add this to our final.
So where's our
spec?
Alright. Case is gonna be weird with it.
So
I wanna add
and then two.
Okay. Into an actual YAML file. Let's go.
We want that.
And we're we're gonna go I think we
could just do a host name. Right? And
we'll just say we don't want to schedule
on admin.
What is this
key
in this case?
Yes. So very good. We need a label.
Could also
so at the beginning, we tainted our we
removed the taint from the from the control
plane. Right?
Maybe we can add that again so that
it doesn't run any workload stuff.
Yeah. We don't have a kube config on
the workers, so that won't work
unless
Let's just
I know that this looks great. So I
could add the master
tape again. I guess that might be quicker.
Kubernetes
master.
Yeah. There's no schedule thing. Right? Can I
add? No. Spoke past it.
Yep.
When the toleration goes on the well, yeah,
there we go. Yeah.
I'm looking at this YAML component. That goes
on the pod. It doesn't
of
course. I do that.
Admin.
I get
pods.
What is key one value one? Is that
do we need that?
I think it is confusing us again.
Yeah. That's that's not gonna be the default.
So if we take a look at anything
running on
let's get something from our cube system namespace
that's running on our admin node, which will
already have the toleration
and then I'll copy the labels. So
I've known.
Let's take a look at here.
That's the admin.
Keep the system.
Add a pod.
Yeah.
I'm on the test.
I'm gonna make that short call.
How am I feeling? So I I I
I have a quicker idea.
How about we scale we scale the deployments
to to one pod,
and then it's only on one node?
Right. Yeah. That would be good.
This is me getting creative.
K. Good. The one I kept is on
the app, man. It's the latest.
Oh, I guess that's fine. Right?
What is fine? Because it it's running on
the admin note, but we're gonna change it
so the service publish doesn't publish the other
note. Right? Exactly. So this is great for
demo purposes. But okay. If you now look
at the routing table, it will still
On the packet?
On packet. Just on the interface.
So we still see that both nodes are
advertising the service
the service center.
But we can configure Calico to only announce
the nodes that actually run
the pods. So we can do this by
editing the
NGINX service.
And we can set this by setting the
external traffic policy to local.
But there is a catch to this. This
only works on node ports, type node port.
And this is just a Kubernetes API quirk.
We're not going to use the node port,
but we need it anyway.
So and then we can set external traffic
policy to local.
We have type cluster IP below
still. We have to remove that.
Yeah.
Okay. And if we apply this,
so
this should still work. We can ignore the
node port. It's only there so that we
have access to this traffic policy thing, and
it's maybe something
that should be fixed in the Kubernetes API.
So Kubernetes
doesn't really
so cluster IPs being exposed externally is not
something that was being thought of originally, I
think. They always thought we'll use external load
balancer objects for this. So you can do
type load balancer, and you'll get something from
your cloud provider.
So here, there's a little bit of an
API mismatch.
But now if we go
to packets and we refresh on the BGP
page the
the routes,
so we press update now.
Has this update now something that can be
done programmatically?
I don't think so. So and because they
also ask us nicely to only do it
every five minutes.
So the the routes are being updated. This
is just about the interface getting the information
from the router and displaying it to you.
So you don't need to press this button
to update the routes. It's just to get
the information
into the interface. That's it.
So now
we should see that
a
let's see if this now works. If you
go to the nodes that is running the
pod.
Oh, yeah. Exactly. We see that it now
announces a a slash 128.
So it says this specific service IP is
exactly on this node.
This is and
if you go to the other one, it
should not be there.
Okay. See? So this now will cause it
only to get routed to that node, and
it will never go to the other node.
But that just reduces the extra hop then
where it doesn't have to go through IPVS
or the Q proxy or the point that
Exactly. Yep.
Yep. So it just avoids this actually does
load balancing itself as well. Right?
So if your your pod workloads are not
evenly distributed over your cluster like we have
now,
all the NGINX pods are
on admin
node, right? So it's receiving all the traffic
right now.
That could also be the case. So if
your pods are not spread
evenly, and this is also not something that
Kubernetes gives you, right? It doesn't give you
even spreads. It does a best effort thing,
but it might come into cases where
resources aren't spread around evenly,
then removing this extra hop through q proxy
can give you an even low balancing.
But
but it does avoid this extra hop, which
is nice.
And Is there any penalties,
whether it be performance or from packet state
how many
groups can be published in that that way?
Like, if I have a relatively large cluster
and I need to
with thousands of services and they're publishing closing
the group, is that is that a challenge?
So
I don't know what the limits are. I'll
there will probably be a limit. And so
Calico has some pages about designing
your
BGP infrastructure. And usually, what you'll have, you
have routers that announce the routers that announce
the routers. You kind of have a trickle
down system
to reduce
the routing tables.
Because usually, you do not announce 10,000 routes
to one router. It will get a bit
confused and it might drop routes or whatever.
So I don't know what the limits are,
to be honest.
Is something
I haven't found in the documentation either.
But if you do bare metal yourself, then
Calico has a very nice tutorial explaining how
you should set up your infrastructure and your
racks and how we there are some different
trade offs that you can make in terms
of network design.
But that's dark magic I do not yet
understand.
But
yeah. So is
are you using a Calico here today
because they're the over CNI offers this or
the one that you're just more familiar with?
Like, do other CNI implementations offer the same
functionality?
I don't know. So
I think Calico is the only one that,
like, allows you to do this.
So what we call this is, like, a
pure layer three network. Classic one where we
use BGP for announcing routes. And also,
you log into one of the boxes and
you type in IP route, you actually see
all the routes listed. And it's very easily
debuggable using so if you do IP dash
six, you have to add a dash six,
otherwise it gets angry.
Like, you'll actually see like this pod's IP
goes through this interface
and
all the other stuff has to go through
the gateway for your default route. So it's
a very classic way of setting up networks,
which also gives you, like, very familiar tools
to debug it for, like
and as soon as you have overlay networks
and stuff and a lot of IP tables
rules, I think these things get less transparent.
And so yes,
I think Calico is the only one.
No, wait, there's another one. KubeRouter also does
this. So there's also KubeRouter, which also does
BGP
routing.
And I think you can also combine that
with Cilium
together,
but I haven't tried those two out.
But I think in terms of having
this BGP by default
approach, I think Calico is probably the most
mature
option out there.
Like this is the thing that they advertise
with. Like this is what we do. We
do flat networking.
But
I know that, for example, Silium has some
other cool tricks, like they have this eBPF
data plane
that you can add,
which avoids having to install Kube proxy.
And I think Calico is also working on
something similar on the eBPF data plane, but
it I checked, and it doesn't work with
I p v six yet. So
I couldn't try it out yet.
Wait. I have a a nice session planned
for next week with someone from the team.
I'm looking forward to learning something. Yeah.
Cool. There is a question if you're feeling
brave.
So Yep. Has asked, when do you recommend
to use reflectors?
So
this is also about, like,
scaling, right? So
I must say, I don't know a lot
about BGP. This is me learning in the
past few weeks and trying things out.
When do you recommend it? From what I
understood from the Calico docs is when you
want to like, usually, Calico sets up a
node to node mesh, and all the nodes
talk to each other.
And that will not scale infinitely.
Right? And instead, you can determine
some certain nodes in your cluster as you
act as the router, I will reflect all
the routes through you so that you don't
have this n times n PGP connections to
announce all the routes.
So I think it's a matter of if
your cluster is starting to scale to
thousands of nodes, you will have to add
these reflectors.
But yes, I haven't had a cluster with
thousands of nodes yet, so I don't know.
But the
there is a
page on the Calico documentation called
Calico over IP Fabrics, and it explains
all the different trade offs you can make
in setting up your Calico network,
like whether you want a node to node
mesh, whether you want route reflectors, whether you
want
this trickle down routing.
But
So, yeah, I I actually think the only
use case is to just scale this note
to note mesh. But in our case, we're
not using the note to note mesh at
all. We're using the packet routers to as
route reflectors, basically.
So
yeah.
Alright. Well,
my brain is now officially fried.
Yeah.
And there is a a lot, I think,
I need to to learn and play with
in that space. And that was a fantastic
you know, just walking through this step by
step and actually seeing how to disable, like,
before and turn on IPv6 and configure the
peers. It's all very valuable and very useful.
So thank you for taking the time to
to join me today and go over all
of that. I
will publish the preliminary automation
in the next couple of days. Is there
anything you would like to finish up with
before we we finish off for the day?
And I'll let you get back to your
lunch or work or whatever.
Well, one thing we didn't cover at all
is, of course, security.
So this might be a fun right?
You you everything is public now, and that's
probably not what you want. Like, I don't
want all my cluster IPs to be publicly
reachable and stuff.
And,
yeah, that's something we haven't configured yet, but
this is something you can do. So Calico
has support for network policies,
which you can describe which pods can talk
to which pods and stuff. And this is
something you should definitely set up after you
set up an IPv6 cluster because
everything is publicly routable, right? And
this might not be what you want, and
you want to close
the fortress a little bit. Yeah.
Yeah. But that's an exercise for the reader.
Yeah. Either that or another two hour stream
eventually in a few months or something. But
we'll see. Yes. So
the the policy stuff is security stuff. Yeah.
Yeah. I can imagine. Right now, everything is
is public, so I'm looking forward to shutting
this customer down before it gets to there.
But
Yep. You also said at the start that
you work for wire, and I believe you
may be tiring just now.
Yeah. So we are hiring for a
operations position.
Experience with Kubernetes would be very helpful, but
not needed per se, because we are so
so WIRE is end to end encrypted chat
platform, collaboration platform, like a Slack competitor.
And we also
run WIRE instances on premise at customers.
And we are migrating our old cloud infrastructure
to our
new cloud infrastructure, which is Kubernetes based. And
so we need people who have knowledge about
on premise hosting and all the dirty nitty
gritties of people other people's shitty networks. And
we need people to help us migrate to
our new cloud infrastructure, so we're looking for
people for that. So,
yeah, feel free to check out jobs.wire.com.
And then
yeah. There's a job ad there. Yep. Cool.
Alright. Well, honestly,
that was really
insightful.
I learned a lot. So thank you very
much for taking the time out to join
me again. And I hope I hope speaks
to you all then. Yeah. See you around.
Bye.
Ciao.